Every country is broke. [music]
Every country is in debt. But somehow
everyone is still getting paid. The
world owes $320 trillion. [music] That's
three times all the money that exists.
So here's the question that breaks
everything. If everyone owes, [music]
who exactly gets paid?
Debt is ancient. Every civilization
tried the same trick. Borrow now, worry
later. And every civilization learned
the same lesson. Debt [music] always
wants control. 5,000 years ago in
Mesopotamia, farmers borrowed grain from
neighbors with simple promises. Pay me
back after harvest, maybe with a little
extra. No banks, no contracts, just
trust. But debts [music] became so
crushing that ancient kings had to
declare debt jubilees, you know, total
forgiveness just to prevent society from
collapsing. Medieval kings were terrible
at paying back. [music] England's Edward
III borrowed $1.5 billion from Italian
banks in the 1340s. Then just didn't
pay. [music] It crashed Europe's
financial system. Philip IVth of France
went further. He arrested his creditors.
[music]
The Knights Templar in 1307. Debt
erased. Problem solved. Everything
changed in 1688. England's parliament
stripped the king's financial control
and said, "From now on, borrowing
happens in the name of the nation, not
the crown." In 1694, [music] the Bank of
England began selling the world's first
government bonds. Ordinary citizens
could lend money to their country, earn
interest, and actually feel [music]
patriotic doing it. But this system had
one limit: gold. Every dollar had to be
backed by actual [music] gold reserves
until 1971 when one president changed
everything. President Nixon announced
the US would no longer exchange dollars
for gold. The Nixon shock ended the gold
[music] standard forever. For decades,
every dollar was backed by gold. $35
could be exchanged for one ounce locked
in Fort [music] Knox. This kept
governments disciplined. But after World
War II, America spent [music] massively
on the Vietnam War, welfare programs,
and global reconstruction. By 1971, the
[music] US had printed so many dollars
that foreign countries, especially
France, started demanding their gold
back. French President Charles [music]
de Gaulle was particularly aggressive,
converting $191 million [music] into
gold in 1965 alone. He literally sent
warships to [music] New York to collect
French gold from American vaults. Other
countries followed. So Nixon said, "No
more." Money [music] became fiat
currency. It exists simply because the
government says so. The result? In 1971,
global debt was just [music] a few
trillion dollars. by 2000, $80 trillion.
Today, $320 trillion, [music]
a 31,400%
increase in 50 years. So, who holds all
this debt?
This is where it gets weird. The answer
isn't China or some shadowy elite.
[music] It's something much more
circular and mundane. The answer is you.
And you're also the one who owes it.
Here's how the trap works. Let's zoom in
on the United States, [music] the
world's most indebted nation, owing $36
trillion. Roughly 70% of US debt is owed
to Americans themselves. [music]
The US borrows from the US. Let me show
you exactly what happens to your money.
You deposit $1,000 in your bank. Your
bank doesn't keep that cash in a vault.
They immediately [music] lend it to the
US government by buying Treasury bonds.
The government spends that $1,000 on
roads, military, social programs,
whatever. The government pays your bank
interest [music] on those bonds. Your
bank gives you a tiny slice of that
interest as your savings account [music]
return. Where does the government get
money to pay that interest from your
taxes? Here's the insane [music] part.
You pay taxes. Arrow. Government pays
interest. Arrow. Your bank gets paid
arrow. You get paid. You're paying
[music] yourself with your own money
through the government. It's a financial
snake eating its own tail. But who holds
all this debt? About $7 trillion [music]
of US debt is held by its own government
agencies and trust funds. Meaning the
government literally owes money [music]
to its own programs. The largest single
piece of that is the Social Security
Trust Fund, which alone holds over $2.7
[music] trillion. That means your
retirement checks are literally backed
by government IO us. It's in your
pension, your bank, your insurance, your
retirement. But it's not just national.
About 30% [music] of US debt is held
overseas. Japan owns $1.1 trillion of US
debt. China owns $816 billion. Even tiny
[music] countries with populations
smaller than some cities own massive
pieces of the US government. And here's
where it gets circular. America owns
$7.86 [music]
trillion in foreign debt from other
countries. Japan owns Chinese debt.
China owns Japanese debt. It's financial
musical chairs where everyone
>> [music]
>> owes everyone else. Global debt doesn't
disappear. It just changes hands. So,
who actually gets paid? Here's the final
answer to the question that started
everything. Nobody gets paid and
everybody [music] gets paid. The system
only works because everyone agrees to
keep playing. Therefore, the entire $320
[music]
trillion global financial system runs on
one single thing, trust. [music]
As long as everyone believes everyone
else will pay, the money keeps
circulating. The snake keeps eating its
tail. The game continues. But what
happens if a country decides to stop
playing?
Simple [music] question. One country
actually tried it. What happened next?
destroyed an entire generation. Greece,
2010. [music]
Investors panicked and stopped buying
Greek bonds. The money tap shut off.
[music] No one would lend Greece another
scent. The European Union made an offer
[music] accept brutal spending cuts or
collapse entirely. They called it
austerity. Here's what it actually
meant. One in four public workers were
fired. Wages fell [music] by 30%. GDP
shrank by 25% in just 5 years. 200,000
young Greeks left the country. College
graduates [music] became waiters in
Berlin. Engineers drove Ubers in London.
Parents watched their children board
planes knowing they [music] might never
come back. The economy didn't recover
for an entire decade. A generation was
[music] lost. And here's the coolest
twist. Greece's debt didn't even go
down. It went up. Because when your
economy [music] collapses, you collect
less in taxes, which means you need to
borrow even more just to survive.
The lesson, you can't just stop. The
machine breaks. But sometimes it's not
about growth, it's about survival. When
CO 19 [music] hit in 2020, people
stopped spending and the economy shut
down. Governments faced the same
nightmare Greece did, but everywhere all
at once. do nothing and then watch
economies collapse [music] or borrow
unthinkable amounts to keep people
alive. Every country made the same
choice. That year, the US government
borrowed an astonishing [music]
$3.8 trillion, nearly 20% of the entire
economy. Japan borrowed $1 trillion.
China borrowed $1.2 trillion. But debt
has a cost, interest. Every year, the US
[music] writes a check for over $1
trillion. Not building schools, not
fixing roads, not curing diseases,
[music]
just paying interest on old loans.
That's more than the entire defense
budget. Money that could change lives
[music] instead pays back banks. And
here's the trap. To pay back old debt,
they borrow more. The debt never [music]
leaves. It just cycles. As long as the
economy grows faster than the debt. This
actually [music] works. Countries like
Norway and Singapore have managed debt
brilliantly for decades. The problem,
[music] most countries aren't Norway.
For developing nations, it's a death
trap. In 2022, 53 [music] countries were
spending more on debt repayment than on
healthcare. They're paying foreign
[music] banks instead of keeping their
own people alive.
Zambia defaulted on $17 billion in debt.
Sri Lanka [music] defaulted for the
first time in its history. The
government ran out of money for fuel
[music] and medicine. People stormed the
presidential palace. Pakistan came
dangerously close. Ghana, Kenya, Egypt,
Tunisia, [music] all teetering on the
edge. And circling above them,
China. Since 2013, China has lent $1
trillion to 150 countries through its
belt and road initiative, ports,
railways, [music] power plants. Sounds
generous, right? But here's the dark
side. Many countries can't pay [music]
back these loans. And when they default,
China doesn't just forgive the debt.
They take control of the assets. In
2017, Sri Lanka couldn't repay its loans
for the Hantoa port project. So, China
took a 99-year lease on the port and
15,000 acres of surrounding land.
[music]
Djibouti owes China 77% of its GDP.
[music] Pakistan owes China $30 billion.
Montenegro borrowed $1 billion, [music]
25% of its GDP for a single highway.
When they [music] couldn't pay, they had
to ask the EU for a bailout to avoid
losing sovereignty. This [music] is the
modern form of colonialism. Debt
imperialism. You don't need to invade a
country. Just lend them money they
[music] can't repay, then take what you
want when they default. And what happens
when confidence breaks? In 2008, [music]
Lehman Brothers collapsed. Credit
markets froze. Banks stopped lending to
each other. Governments had to step in
with 12 trillion in bailouts [music]
worldwide just to keep banks afloat. Now
imagine an entire country defaulting,
not Greece, [music] something bigger.
Italy with $3.2 trillion in debt. Or
Japan [music]
with 14.8 trillion. The shock would
cascade through the global financial
system like dominoes falling.
Print your way out. Venezuela tried. By
2019, 9,586%
[music]
inflation. Coffee that cost 2,300
believers in the morning could cost you
6,000 by afternoon. [music]
People carried bags of cash for bread.
Zimbabwe did the same thing in 2008,
reaching an inflation rate of 79.6
billion% per month. They eventually
[music] abandoned their currency
entirely and started using US dollars.
You can't cheat [music] math. Print
money, lose your currency. Stop
borrowing. Collapse your economy.
There's no [music] escape hatch. The
lesson is clear. There's no easy escape
from debt.
So, who does the world owe? The answer?
You, me, [music] your neighbor.
>> Hi.
>> We owe each other. We owe ourselves.
Your savings, [music] your pension, your
insurance. All part of this massive
loop. The system works [music] until it
doesn't. Because debt is built on one
thing, trust. Which is why China,
Russia, India, [music] Turkey, they're
all stockpiling gold. Preparing for when
that trust [music] breaks. Right now,
global debt increases by $100,000
[music] every second. So, here's what
you should really be asking. If the
system runs on trust and [music]
everyone's borrowing from everyone else,
what happens the day we stop trusting
each other? Not a villain, not a secret
group. It owes you and you owe it.